بدون ذلك نقلت وكاله ينهب عن رئيس كوريا
الجنوبيه جون سوكيون انه يجب ان تكون هناك
خشيه من كوريا الشماليه بسبب السلاح
النووي وان اي استفزازات من جانب بيونغ
يجب ان تقابل برد الانتقامته ينهب نقلت عن
مسؤولين كوريين جنوبيين ان الرئيس
ساسوكيول وبخ وزير الدفاع لجون بسبب ما
وصفها بالعمليه الفاشله للجيش ضد خمس
طائرات كوريه شماليه مسيره داخل المجال
الجويه لكوريا في وقت سابقا من هذا
الاسبوع
اعلى سعيد اخر اعلن في اليابان ان رئيس
الوزراء الياباني فوم يوكيشي ده سيعقد
لقاء قمه في واشنطن مع الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن في الثالث عشر من يناير المقبل
السياسه الامنيه الجديده لبلاده والتي جرى
تعديلها هذا الشهر لتكشف عن اكبر عمليه
تطوير لقدرات اليابان العسكريه منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه
وانت تتابعينا اذا هذا الملف عن قرب لعلك
ايه تشرحين لنا اكثر
نعم صباح الخير ازدهار وعثمان الزعيم
الكوريه الشماليه كيم جون اون خلال خطابي
امام اجتماع حزب العمال الحكم في بيوم
بيانغ ركز على تطوير الدفاعات العسكريه
البحريه والجويه على وجه الخصوص خلال
العام الجديد عام 2023 ياتي هذا بعد ايام
قليله من اطلاق بيونغ يونغ لمس سيارات
لاول مره من خمس سنوات اخترقت المجال
الجويه لكوريا الجنوبيه ولم تستطع
الدفاعات الكوريه الجنوبيه اسقاط هذه
المسيارات التركيز خلال خطاب كيم كان على
تطوير المسيارات على وجه الخصوص تحدث عن
برنامج كوريا الشماليه في تطوير
وسيارات وطائرات بدون طيار جديده من نوع
جديد اليوم يمكن ان تطير لمسافه تصل الى
500 كلم
عن تطوير وتكثيف التجارب الصاروخيه ليس
الباريستيه فقط بل التجارب الصاروخيه
عموما
حدثون عن عام 2022 الذي كان العام الاكثر
ارتفاعا من ناحيه اعداد التجارب الصاروخيه
الكوريه الشماليه وصلت لي اثنتين و تسعين
تجربه صاروخيه خلال عام واحد فقط وهي
الاعلى مقارنه بالسنوات السابقه الشهر
الماضي وحده عثمان شهر نوفمبر وحده شهيده
اطلاق
سته واربعين تجربه صاروخيه نصف هذه
التجارب الصاروخيه الكوريه الشماليه اين
تحدث عن 23 تجربه كلها اجريت خلال يوم
واحد فقط هو يوم الثاني من نوفمبر الماضي
كل هذه التجارب الصاروخيه راتها الجار
الكوريه الجنوبيه راتها ايضا اليابان على
انها تهديدات مباشر من بيونديال لامن
واستقرار همم سول وتوفي والمنطقه على وجه
العموم وكانت قد قامت به همم مناورات
عسكريه مشتركه بحريه وجويه مع الحليفه
الاستراتيجيه الاولى لكوريا
المتحده الامريكيه خلال الشهر الماضي اتت
ردا على الاستفزازات الكوريه الشماليه كما
وصفتها طوكيو غوسول اذا نتحدث عن تطوير
الدفاعات العسكريه خلال عام 2023 ضمن خطه
بدات فيها الاداره اداره بيونغ او اداره
كيم جونغ اون منذ العام الماضي بالحديث عن
هذه المسيارات الجديده وضروره تطويرها
لحمايه الاراضي الكوريه الشماليه من
التهديدات الاقليميه كما وصفتها وتنامي
المناورات العسكريه التي تجريها السول
وتوكيو واشنطن في المنطقه كيم جون اون
ايضا كانت قد تحدث خلال اجتماع حزب العمال
الحاكم فيه فيهم الذي يقام كل خمس سنوات
عن ضروره تطوير المنظومه الغواصات الكوريه
الشماليه للتصدي ل اا هجمات محتمله من
الجاره الكوريه الجنوبيه وايضا من اليابان
خلال
سنوات المقبله هنالك برنامج همم الدفاعي
جديد يتحدث عنه كيم جون اون يقول بانه
ضروري لي التصدي ايضا لاي هجمات تاتي من
دول غربيه على راسها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
وان كان كم لم يتحدث عن واشنطن بالاسم لكن
دائما ما تكون واشنطن هي على راس الدول
الغربيه التي تراها في يوم التهديد الاكبر
في المنطقه
شكرا جزيلا